[Music]
on tv
on radio and on your smartphone this is
talk tv
[Music]
well good evening welcome to extended
two-hour special edition of piers morgan
unsensed i am pierce morgan with you
till 10 o'clock so here it is then the
third caroline era his majesty king
charles iii the queen is dead
god save the king still feels strange
doesn't it to say those words it will
take getting used to it let's be honest
but already i feel like it's less
strange than it seemed even two days ago
already the shock and the sadness of the
queen's passing is turning into protests
process and pragmatism
and that after all is the british way
isn't it the late queen herself did that
better than anybody we keep calm and we
carry on and we carry out our historic
customs with the pageantry pomp and
class that is unmatched anywhere else in
the world
and today honestly i feel proud i feel
proud of the
huge numbers of people who've come out
to pay their own personal tribute to the
queen all on their own time i'm proud of
the ceremonies and processions that
britain truly does best i'm proud of the
new king too
smiling through his
intense grieve this is the man who lost
his father and now his mother all in the
space is what 18 months
there he is smiling with the public
shaking their hands
taking the odd kiss
and he's making powerful speeches
so whatever's going on inside whatever
turmoil he's going through as a man
loved his mother
we're seeing a king
at the top of his game from day one just
as his mother was
when i watched him this morning talking
to mps and peers in the famous
westminster hall
i couldn't find a word he said just as i
couldn't with his national address
the other night
that hall of course is a place where guy
fawkes and charles the first were put on
trial it's where king george and the
queen mother lay in state it said
speeches from everyone from christchurch
to president reagan and the pope a
thousand years of history in one room
where else in the world do you get that
today felt like a new chapter in that
history in our history and i'm feeling
good about it a lot of people feared for
the future of the monarchy without the
late queen i'm a good reason i've had my
doubts myself
but the more i see and hear already from
king charles iii the more reassured i am
about the future of our monarchy and
about the kind of king he's going to be
and in her death the queen seemingly
managed to reunite some of the warring
factions of the royal family themselves
however temporarily
she's also reminded us hasn't she of
the values she held and what those
values mean to being british and her son
who's now taken over from her i think
shares those values
not for the first time the late queen
has made us incredibly proud of this
country well joining me now is talk tv
political editor kate mccann from
westminster talk tv correspondent
miranda schunker who's at buckingham
palace let's go to miranda first uh
miranda bucky and palace
could be very emotional tomorrow the
queen at the moment is uh in scotland uh
that's where her body is is currently
lying in state and people are
passing by to pay their respects there
but tomorrow she'll come back to uh by a
plane to london to buckingham palace for
the last time to buckingham palace a
great home in the capital city and i
suspect we're going to see quite
remarkable scenes there tomorrow and of
course very different to the scenes that
we saw in the jubilee celebrations
yes indeed i mean i've been here every
day since friday and i've just seen the
numbers grow and grow there is a steady
stream of people coming here coming
along the palace gates and then over to
green park where a lot of the floral
tributes have now been moved there is
literally tens of thousands of floral
bouquets that people are really taking
in some people spending many hours here
today but what i have seen today what's
different is that a people management
operation has really swung into action
today there are barriers everywhere
there are high-vis security men
everywhere they're under strict
instruction to not even let people cross
the road in certain places so they're
really
stepping up the organization out ahead
and i think it's probably because they
want to get very organized ahead of next
monday we're quite some time away from
that yet but the numbers are only going
to grow
in the next 24 hours and obviously we've
seen a lot of focus up in scotland
understandably today but that focus is
really going to shift to here tomorrow
as we know the queen's coffin will be
flown down around six o'clock to raf
north old before br
before being brought here as you say to
buckingham palace to spend
the final night in the palace before
being moved to westminster hall so it
will be a very emotional day it promises
to be a very busy day here again and i
think people are just trying to take in
this moment of history they're looking
at the spectacle of this and people are
very emotional and they want it to go
successfully and they want it to really
go well for not only for the queen
herself but also for the family yeah i
gotta say i think that so far this has
been an unbelievable
uh display of supreme logistics by the
people who've been organizing this and i
know they've had plenty of time to
prepare but you can never really prepare
for this kind of thing it's a one-off in
our lifetime i'm just uh reading here
the prince and princess of wales will be
at buckingham palace when the queen's
coffin arrives tomorrow that's just been
announced and the queen's four children
have been performing the traditional
vigil of course of the princes around
the coffin of the late mothers and girls
cathedral in edinburgh that is now uh
finished i think they've just concluded
that um so this is all going isn't it um
miranda in a way that i i think it is
showing the world actually what this
country does best
nobody does pomp and pageantry
either in good times or bad in weddings
or jubilee celebrations or funerals or
burials whatever it may be
we do this kind of thing i think in a
way that no other country can come close
to emulating
i mean absolutely they've been planning
this for years we know that but i think
the general public feels a great sense
of unity a great sense of identity and
people here want to be together they are
very very supportive of the monarchy it
seems as i talk to many people here they
are very much behind this they want
everything to go successfully and they
want to play their part in it they
certainly are doing so here today and
that is only going to grow in the days
ahead up until the funeral on monday but
i should say that uh the the queen's
coffin will lie in state for four days
and people will be able to start filing
past that coffin from wednesday at five
o'clock until 6 30 on monday morning
yeah and i think i mean thank you
miranda i think people should go down
there this is the piece of history this
is your chance to go and just pay your
own little tribute to
this remarkable person this great
towering figure in this country's
history you know i remember the scenes
when uh it actually happened just before
i was born literally the month before
winston churchill died in 1965 and they
were predicting certain numbers of
people to turn out apparently it was
just off the charts wrong in terms of
underestimating how many the public
turned out for churchill i think this is
going to dwarf anything including that
that we've ever seen i think by the time
we get to the state funeral on monday
it's going to be the greatest event of
its kind we've ever seen in this country
uh kate mccann obviously down at
westminster where all this will happen
of course on monday and where the queen
will be lying in state for four days
okay what's the atmosphere like because
when it was the jubilee celebrations it
was one of joy and celebration and
everything else
this is not the kind of shock raw
feeling is it on the streets when like
when diana died when it was so
shocking because she was so young there
was a car crash and everything else this
is
i think it feels to me watching it all
like a very dignified and respectful
collection of people up and down the
country just wanting to pay respects
yeah i think it's exactly that i was in
that session in westminster hall that
you were talking about this morning when
the king was given the address and gave
the address to both houses of parliament
you know mps peers journalists was
around 1 500 of us in that hall and
really it is one of the most historic
and special parts of the whole of the
palace of westminster there really is
something about it even when it's
completely empty maybe particularly then
there's something about that room and
the feeling in there today was one of
warmth it felt like there were far fewer
people actually than there were and yes
this is a king who is grieving the death
of his mother
but he was in reasonably good spirits he
was emotional when god saved the king
was sung he looked like he was fighting
back tears at a couple of different
moments but he also talked about the
weight of history on his shoulders and
as he was leaving he was smiling and
thanking people and saying hello to
those who were gathered there and it
felt like quite a nice moment and i
think that's going to continue i am
actually standing on part of the route
that people are going to cue up when
they go and pay their respects to the
queen who will lie in state in
westminster hall and we know that there
are already some people gathering at the
other end of this pathway they've
already started queueing we expect that
queue will go right back across east
london it could be 20 or even 30 hours
if people queue for that whole distance
but i get the sense that there will be a
really nice atmosphere here people are
excited and you're right there isn't
that outpouring of real raw grief
because there is a feeling that the
queen had a great life and that's
something that needs to be celebrated as
we move through the next week yeah i
completely agree well let's take a
little look at the clip actually from
charles's speech king charles the third
speech to give him his correct title of
course now this is to the mps and peers
this morning
i cannot help but feel the weight
of history
which surrounds us
and which reminds us
of the vital parliamentary traditions
to which members of both houses
dedicate yourselves
with such personal commitment
for the betterment of us all she set an
example
of selfless duty
which
with god's help
and your counsels
i am resolved faithfully to follow
so kay i think one of the key things of
course is going to be the relationship
between the new king and our new prime
minister i mean i keep sort of shaking
my head slightly the fact that in one
week in the space of four days 72 hours
actually
uh under four days
we had a new prime minister and a new
monarch i mean that's probably never
gonna happen again in in history so an
extraordinary few days in this country's
history and that relationship between
liz truss
and charles iii is going to be crucial
isn't
it yeah appears if you're shaking your
head imagine how liz trust feels a few
days into that job she's not even really
had her cabinet all together to talk
about spending tens of billions maybe
hundreds of billions of pounds on an
energy policy
and now she's thrust into this very
public role alongside a new king who as
you say is also trying to adjust to a
big change in circumstances i mean he of
course has had far longer to prepare for
this and he really understands the role
in a way that liz trust perhaps can't
yes she's been in cabinet for some time
but she's never been prime minister
before she's never been the one to take
those final decisions all the one to
walk in front of the camera lenses she
walked behind king charles today leaving
westminster hall and her face was fixed
it looked pained it looked like somebody
who was under a huge amount of pressure
and that is hardly surprising because
she is she will be joining him at those
ceremony ceremonial occasions in
scotland northern ireland and wales over
the course of the next couple of days
and that in itself is a huge ask and
then she of course has her on the
diplomatic stage she has all the phone
calls she has to conduct with other
prime ministers all of that that she has
to focus on while still now managing her
role in what would be a very public
grief but also trying to guide the
country through that and i think we saw
that in the commons last week with those
tributes and boris johnson of course
making a really heartfelt speech some
suggesting that liz trust didn't quite
rise to that occasion but as you say you
know two people taking on huge mantles
at a very difficult time for the country
and please it'll be fascinating to see
how they work together whether they
decide to go their own way and steer
their own course amongst of course the
conventions that they have to stick to
yeah and this extraordinary thing on uh
about the dignitaries coming for the
state funeral there's going to be we
think 2 000 in total but they're being
limited to one
i think one official per country with
their spouse or other half and it's you
think about that means president biden
for example and his wife the first lady
jill biden will be the only
representatives from the united states
apparently
at the funeral because they're going to
have to get everybody else in from every
other country because the demand to be
there from every country in the world is
going to be overwhelming but it's a
remarkable thing and apparently they're
not going to be allowed to come in on
private jets they have to come into
fixed airports or they had to find their
own way somewhere in the country won't
be allowed to use helicopters into
central london they've got to use these
uh cars and buses i think they've been
laid on it's going to be a very
extraordinary spectacle watching the
most powerful people in the world
basically having to slum it a bit by
comparison to the to how some of them
would normally be treated
but part of the reason for that is
exactly what you said before that there
has been a history of underestimating
the public appetite for coming along and
paying their respects and getting
involved in occasions like this there
have been huge estimates for the number
of people who will line this route where
i'm currently standing over the course
of the next couple of days but those who
are planning it inside government worry
that even those numbers touching on a
million may well be underestimating
things and i think you're getting a
sense of that when you hear them talk
about look don't bring children to the
queue it'll be really hard work you
can't sleep you'll have to keep moving
it could be 20 hours there's a lot of
expectation management going on and
there's a huge policing operation too in
the time i've been stood here we've seen
a number of police officers walking up
and down this route volunteers and
high-vis vests that's putting pressure
actually on a number of other events
that would usually be policed including
football matches which we've seen a
number of them cancelled they'll be
police stationed in uh railway stations
and other transport areas and there is a
lot of concern that there could be a
potential for protesters to try and get
involved to mark the route and also the
pressure that will just put on london as
a transport hub it struggles sometimes
at the best of times strikes have been
called off but all of those people
flocking here trying to pay their
respects it's not just keeping the city
moving but it's also making sure that
people feel that everything has gone off
well this operation has been planned for
months and months and months but you
cannot plan for the scale of outpouring
of grief that i think we are going to
see here and there is some worry and
some tension about that yeah kate mccann
thank you very much appreciate it well
i'm joined now by the sun's royal
photographer arthur edwards political
journalist ava santina and talk to the
presenter richard tight arthur great to
have you uh i really i thought of you
actually very soon after i heard this
news because it hit me hard when i was
took a phone call from someone a friend
of of uh the new king now on his queen
consul who just said the queen has
passed and it was before it was it had
been announced or confirmed and i felt a
real you know like uh someone punched me
and i know i remember quite quickly
thinking i wonder how you were because
you've been such a huge part of covering
the lives
of the royals and in particular this
queen
how did you feel when you heard how did
you hear the news well i heard the news
on the bb on the bbc i think and but um
i was at the top at dunphrey's house
with the prince the night before at a
par uh the other dinner there and um
you know it was a jovial it was a great
evening and then the following day i
just saw everybody clear out the hotel
quickly so there was and it was then i
knew that something had happened and
then of course
when we got the news it was yeah i felt
for the prince actually because like you
were saying it's difficult for him
trying to cope with the loss of his
mother i mean your mother's your best
friend right okay you are who you are in
this world your mother's your best and
he just lost his father and he just lost
his father but now then he was then he
had to go and put a brave face on
everywhere
and i just think he's had a brilliant
job and that speech he made and i think
he's made a great start i totally agree
with the king and i think he's been
incredibly moved and encouraged by the
warmth of the reaction from the public
because he must have been slightly
wondering
once his mother died this unbelievably
popular monarch the greatest in my view
in history he must have been just
wondering i wonder how the public will
react to me but the answer has been with
enormous warmth and i think that's
really
helped him through what has been a
professional
difficult period where he's got to
become this new model but also
personally when he's
grief-stricken we saw princess anne in
the car behind the hearse yesterday for
a few hours looking completely anguished
yeah and you understand why she lost
both her parents yeah so is king charles
and yet we were expecting him to just
get out there and be the king i mean i
couldn't even imagine being that strong
actually in that situation well he's i
mean he always said you know
history will judge me and now he's come
out now as the king and people are
seeing him from for the man he is the
man i've been working with what is he
like he's a fantastic person he knows
everybody in the world he knows
every prime minister every head of state
he's so well connected and he's and he's
just traveled the world i mean we were
miranda in june with all the heads of
government there and they all paid great
homage to him i remember one person get
down on their knees before him when he
came in there from papua new guinea and
and you know he is i just
the reason i still work peers is because
i work with this man and
and the queen the new queen camilla
they're just fabulous people and really
that's really great for me oh yeah i i
just
i really enjoy it if i've got a job with
with with
say the prince if i had a job at the
king
the next job which he will be um
probably um on wednesday when they
follow the coffee
i will look to him but he will be solid
well you had an amazing little moment
with him uh after his mother died after
the queen passed and it was captured by
a photographer and you had just a short
exchange with him but tell me what he
said to you well he came off the plane
and uh i was the only photographer that
the raf lady took that
and um
he just came up to me and he said you're
okay and i said yes sir i said i'm very
sorry about your loss
and he said well it had to happen
someday i think yeah i had to have him
one day he said yeah and i
and then he just pat me on the arm and
you're okay and he went off i mean
arthur what a moment for you
yeah and for him because he recognized
that you would probably be feeling very
upset about this but for you to have the
new king
of this country
actually inquiring as to how you're
feeling
and having that exchange with you is a
remarkable thing for anybody yeah but on
the wednesday night at the party we were
laughing together you know we were
joking together and this there was like
you know 24 hours later there he is
we're sort of
he's he's coping and he's not worried
he's worried about me and i just
you know i said fine
but it was i was a bit overcome by it
and are you surprised arthur that i mean
if you go back it was 25 years last week
since diana's death yeah and if you
remember as i know you do but if the
people watching the art in the aftermath
of that a lot of hostility towards
charles and camilla who many people
blame for the breakup of the marriage i
never thought it was as straightforward
as that at all um
but here we are now 25 years later
they've been married for 17 years
it's extraordinary to me to watch
their pathway back to public popularity
in the way that it's gone and and very
encouraging well just did it for hard
work you know put their head down and
got on with it certainly the
the new queen i was going to say the
duchess but camilla she just put
everything into it she took only over
200 patronages and she's she's just
tirelessly as well but the most
important thing
is she supports the prince like for
instance when they got off the plane at
northall the other day he came down and
she stayed back in the cabin until he
met the
the station commander and then she came
down you know and she's like she's done
it all the way she's never ever
uh hold the limelight in fact um
i just
she is just perfect for him i think
camilla is correct well the queen
console yeah
her correct title and in fact i i saw a
bbc instruction earlier that you should
stop talking about the late queen as the
queen because actually camilla is now
automatically queen console and that
should be a title for her and these
things are important i've known uh the
queen console a long time and got to
know quite well actually and sat next to
her at dinner parties and things like
that she's an incredibly down-to-earth
decent woman actually she never lost the
common touch she never did no and she's
never she she has that effortless uh
sense of non-entitlement which the queen
has a sense you never feel like she
feels she's entitled to any of this no
you know she loved this man and if you
think about it in a way it was it's been
one of the great love stories it's
endured everything absolutely and
there's no doubt to me that camilla has
made him happier than anybody else
absolutely and settled and calm and much
more calm about approaching things yeah
you know he's he had a little bit of a
sparky temper you know i've not seen
that for a long while no i mean not for
a long while and i mean i've had some
serious
telling off to him you know but you have
you've also had some great moments after
i want to play you one this is from 2018
where charles gives his views on you
he's a very good photographer
and a truly good bloke i think
and a very special person and
none of our overseas visits i can assure
you something will be the same
without arthritis there
and i get more and more worried because
he's a bit further advanced than we are
and i always worry about the number of
cameras and bits of equipment that he
carries in boiling hot countries
so
anyway i'm so grateful to
for all your kindness today
i mean that's a pretty remarkable that
man's the king of this country now you
know paying that tribute yeah that
chokes me up a bit when he said yeah
because
i mean i didn't expect that i made a
little speech in welcoming this was his
70th birthday party we held for him at
the
spencer house and uh
i welcomed him and i talked about you
know it wasn't always like this you know
there were times when it was a little
bit hostile you know when kelvin was the
editor
and uh
but you know what happened i started to
see what this man was doing and i and i
listened to his speeches i was there
when he when he was begging the uh the
the president of brazil to stop ripping
up the rainforest and if he thinks he's
got away with it now i don't think
prince charles is going to give up he'll
be giving the prime minister a little
bit of his mind about that you know
about the environment he he probably
won't be able to say anything publicly
but he certainly won't give up
richard what's your take been on in
other words with you that the on the
night of course and that was very sad
evening indeed
as we've moved on now we're beginning to
look ahead as well as recognize the
enormous contributions this late queen
made as we look ahead to king charles
iii are you as encouraged as i am i
think arthur is by the start he's made
completely appears it's as though he's
grown a foot taller in in strength in
confidence and i think he's drawing
strength and reassurance from his
subjects
and actually we his subjects are also
drawing comfort and reassurance from
from from his strength and for how he's
conducting himself for the way that this
is just seamlessly
transitioning
from
from the late queen
from all of her extraordinary
achievements but actually i really do
think this is this is going to give the
whole nation real confidence i draw huge
strength from it much more than i think
any of us could possibly have expected
david do you see yourself as a subject
do people your age even like the idea of
being anyone's subject and is that an
issue for the future of the monarchy i
think it's a difficult question at the
moment in this 10-day period of morning
because i mean look it's a subject
steeped in history which i think is
fascinating i think that a lot of people
can have massive appreciation for but
you know
i i don't think that we also need to
feel
as subject so i don't i think it's
perfectly okay to be quite sad about the
queen and to appreciate her legacy but
also say you know there's quite a few
things around the monarchy that i don't
really appreciate and like what in your
case well today for example i didn't
really appreciate police officers using
the 2022 uh police bill
to drag protesters off the streets and
say that we weren't allowed to object to
the monarchy i mean i didn't appreciate
i mean i didn't like what they were
saying but i absolutely defend their
right to protest
and there are a body of people in this
country who will agree with some of
these prejudices take a look at some of
the protest today
it's interesting that particular
incident because i think it's completely
disrespectful to have done that anywhere
near the queen's
heart obviously however i also thought
it was a big risk
by the royal family to let prince andrew
after all that's gone on with him in the
last year
walk through the streets in that way
now they would say and i understand this
he was a beloved son of the queen and
she would famously described him to
people sometimes apparently her favorite
son i'm not sure that's actually true
but that was what was reported
but
it notwithstanding that it's only a few
months ago that he paid off a woman who
accused him of sexually abusing her
millions and millions of dollars having
said he'd go to court and clear his name
is it irrational for some people
to think this is completely
inappropriate
well i mean he he didn't pay let's be
clear about that we paid we the taxpayer
paid that and you know
i would say that it was disrespectful
to her and her legacy actually to the
people who love the queen for him to
walk behind the carriage i thought that
was really disrespectful actually you
know i think it's really i'm sorry he is
a grieving son for his mother i think i
think it's mean-spirited i think it's
heartless frankly you know we a nation
are grieving but they are a family yep a
family in greece i think his siblings
would have wanted okay but in any other
situation would a family
walk through the entire nation to pay
their respects so they don't need to be
there for the entire funeral this is
this is the royal family
this is you know and yes but that i
think is a sign of the openness and the
transparency with which charles is going
to govern open and transparent we could
talk about the fact that a lot of people
have had to cancel the funerals for
their own mothers because of the queen
and respect and homage to the queen and
there are a lot of people at the moment
who are actually having to rent coffins
because they can't afford to buy them so
if we're going to talk about respect we
should talk about it across the board
and we should have a little bit of
nuance well i think that actually it's
about people's love and appreciation and
devotion to our monarch the queen to the
queen
what is your view of this andrew
situation
i i mean i i didn't like for example
that he wore his military uniform for
the vigil apparently it's the only part
of the entire
where he'll wear a military uniform but
if you're in one of the regiments that
he did represent i know there's a lot of
ill feeling towards him from members of
those regiments that he still
seems like he's representing them after
what he did now
what do you think well i was there in
portsmouth when he came back after the
falklands war and we were cheering him
and we were only we laid his life on the
line for this country
i've worked with him for years and i
really like him and he's made a big
mistake in his life which was giving
that interview to emily maitland i don't
care what you say i mean if he'd have
said to her i did do that i was lonely
there was a mistake and i apologize it
was would have none of this trouble but
the fact that he lied was the mistake
now well hang on
that may not be the only mistake he made
i must be clear he paid a woman to avoid
having his supposed day in court he paid
him millions of dollars it may be that
he was guilty of what she accused him of
otherwise why are you paying someone
millions of dollars we don't know that
and we're never going to find out now
but it may not have been his only
mistake
to do that interview well
okay fine all right but it was
highlighted he made a mistake in his
life we've all made mistakes in our life
we'd like to be highlighted every one of
us you me
i've never ever had to pay 12. we
haven't no we wouldn't have to do that
because you're not a prince of the realm
that's why
and the fact is that
you know i think he should be walking
behind his mother's coffin i think he
should if he of course i do i mean it's
god he's grieving his broken heart
should people who are angry about it be
treated in the way that protests i don't
think people should be allowed to sort
of disrupt that that
that comment or the queen sorry i
thought you were going to go on the
other side of it no i don't think no no
no i i i you know i agree with you you
have your right to say it but there are
times when you you don't do it well i
think it's wrong i think it's
inappropriate to do it
but i don't think they should start
being pulled away manhandled or arrested
arrested some of them have
i mean i'll be really living in a
country where people get arrested for
exercising their right to free speech to
protest
exactly
it's a fine balance judgment but the
reality is you know this is a democracy
and in a sense i think they've got the
right to grieve as a family it's not
prince andrew's choice you know he's
he's got a right to agree with his
father argue that they fought for our
freedom or you know
you can't argue that he fought for our
freedom and then when someone says
something you don't particularly like
arrest them okay listen let's we're
going to come back to us later in the
program but for now just stay with me uh
panel uh next time the queen was often
the happiest when she was at the races
i'll be joined by two people who rode
and trained more than a hundred winners
for the late queen frankie to tory and
nikki henderson
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well one of queen of elizabeth ii's
greatest passions was horses she took up
riding age three and got in the saddle
as recently as last year she also
famously loved of course horse racing
and joining me now are two people who
rode and trained more than 100 winners
for the late queen frankie de torre who
wrote more than 50 winners for the queen
and nikki henderson who was a late
monarch's racehorse trainer for more
than two decades well thank you both so
much for joining me i know how much both
of you meant
to her majesty the late queen frankie
where were you when you heard that the
queen had died and how did you feel in
that moment
well obviously thursday i was sorry it
was uh it was thursday was a doncaster
and i heard the news that
bucky and palace made a statement and
straight away we knew things were not
good
and then in the evening was announced
that she passed away and
look i i know i made the queen for 30
years and every time i seen her she had
this horror of
immortality so
when the news came that she passed away
it was a
feeling of shock a feeling of emptiness
not just me all the people around me or
the whole country really was uh
yeah i mean we would not prepare for
this and you know i know she was 96 and
you know
but nobody was expecting it just all of
a sudden and uh yeah it's really really
really uh
took everybody uh
by surprise and
you know it's been now three days
uh there is a
sense of emptiness
in the country
a lot of silence and
yeah we
really
tried to cope with it really
she was in england's
mother but really
we're part of this country and we feel
you know part of it you know uh and you
know we are
uh try to uh
deal with it
nikki you performing the queen mother's
trainer and then the queen inherited
horses you spent so much time
around these two great women i had the
pleasure of meeting both of them and
they were indomitable women in many ways
but their love of horses and horse
racing was very real wasn't it
well it was spectacular i think because
because most of all we all know that
the work and the duty that the queen and
the queen mother herself beforehand had
put into the country and
horse racing and the horses i think
really owned
overall were her one little downtime
hobby
pleasure something she really really
enjoyed incredibly knowledgeable
um
and it was
it was a very big part of her life
racing's only a very small community
really in the big picture
but she was our patron our best friend
and racing was very very lucky to have
her
um for all those years
um
you know as as the biggest supporter
and and somebody who got so much
pleasure out of it and she just loved
the horses i think the people were part
of it as well
but um you know we just everybody will
have very very happy memories
of some some great days what was your
what was your greatest great supporter
what was your greatest moment with nikki
when you look back
i think really when you say was an
enormous privilege and honor to be there
with the having had the horses for the
queen mother queen mother really only
had the jumpers
and the queen had flat horses so they
sort of had their own
separate identities there when the queen
mother died um
the queen inherited the horses um
she probably inherited me as well i
don't know whether she wanted me but
i was there and
um we've had some wonderful days and i
think just i think that the sort of a
lot of the memories would be
i think the breeding side of it is what
she really enjoyed she loved the stud
the planning of the matings as we would
call it which stallions the mayors would
go to
and then the foals being born and the
dreams that were then born with them
and
i think the greatest pleasure is
probably actually wandering around
sandringham stud where they all lived
and were born and bred
and
you know looking forward to the future
looking at horses they were not going to
run for three or four years we were only
doing that earlier in the year and she
was planning for five years time
um and i think as frank said i think we
all thought she was immortal but sadly
nobody is and you know therefore we have
this enormous void and
but this wonderful country of that has
ceased served so brilliantly but now you
see
that how much she meant to them yeah and
i think that has just been the last few
days have been unbelievable i completely
agree uh frankie you had 50 winners
can you remember one as being the
standout were you you had your great
moment with with her majesty
listen i i know imagine i knew her for
30 years and up to the last time i met
her i was
absolutely petrified to meet her about
every time i met her she made you feel
welcome
and uh she make you you know you you had
this sense of uh
uh great feeling after you met her and
obviously
my biggest win for her when i was uh in
my 20s i was only a young boy and uh but
but the the feeling that you got
to
meta it was unbelievable and you never
knew how to kind of conduct yourself you
didn't know if you wanted to shake your
hands or to bow but she made you feel so
comfortable and it was always
you know even after 30 years you always
have that beautiful mystery and
well-being factor that we need when you
met her she was a wonderful wonderful
person and if you lost by a tight head
on a red hot favorite owned by the queen
frankie were there threats to take you
to the tower of london
well i did actually a few times but she
was always a great loser maybe she was
burning inside it but she never showed
that she was always conducting herself
in in an amazing way and i'm sure like
at the fuels is the loss
for for her majesty and is that right
nick
well she was you right to say not only
she was a very gracious winner and i
think we'd all sort of remember the
pictures of when estimate won the ask at
gold cup i mean the pure joy that she
had out of that
um but then the wonderful thing was when
things went wrong and they do with
horses they're fickle creatures
and they can't talk
um and
she understood them so if things went
wrong or horses well lots of horses
don't win so they can't always we're
always trying to get them to win but she
got enormous pleasure out of winning but
she was the most fantastic loser or the
bearer of bad
bad news
um she understood
the horses and the people that were
with them and she she just
she made it very very easy for us
well there's no doubt that you two
probably brought more pleasure to her
majesty than
probably anyone i know actually because
the things she loved was horse racing
and you kept bringing her winners time
and again so gentlemen thank you so much
for both of you for joining me tonight
to pay tribute to her majesty it will
meant a lot to i'm sure what you've been
saying so thank you very much
well coming up the former fab four as
they were called show the united front
and they did well wishes this is just a
temporary truce on a much more
deep-rooted rift
should harry and megan be forgiven for
all that's happened or will harry's
forthcoming tell-all book
actually make things a hell of a lot
worse we'll talk about that after the
break
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
this is talk tv
[Music]
well william harry kate and megan came
together to view tributes to the queen
on saturday of windsor a show of
apparent unity but after the way the
sussexes have badmouthed the monarchy
for the last couple of years should they
be forgiven and welcomed back
or will harry's forthcoming tell-all
book actually make things a lot worse
joining me i've discussed this former
royal protection officer ken ward family
law barrister paul of rhone adrian
ambassador photographer arthur roberts
is still with me
ken
this is a hard one isn't it because my
understanding of what actually happened
was that prince william now the new
prince of wales could see that the
entire week was going to get taken up
the stories of the rift and who was
going to sit where at the various
ceremonies and so on
and he thought he'd get ahead of it as
my understanding and he texted harry and
said we're going to go and walk about
why don't you come as well and let's
just try and defuse things
and harry agreed and then they spent 45
minutes getting ready because they
weren't expecting it and then they all
went out together there was no doubt
it's a powerful image of unity but i
don't think anyone should be too fooled
that this actually is the end of the
problem and one of the biggest issues is
this tell-all book that harry has
written which is due to be published by
penguin random house we don't know when
potentially even in the next couple of
months and if it does and it's really
critical
of the man who's now king his father and
it's critical of the woman he's now
queen console and it's critical of the
heir to the throne the prince of wales
prince william this is going to cause
incredible new damage probably worse
than anything they've done already what
do you think of this
well i mean i agree i agree with what
you say i mean if if what you say
were to appear in this book and and if
this book were to be published within
the next or the foreseeable future and
and if that's what's written that it is
going to cause you know i think
extraordinary damage
my personal belief is i think that you
know this will be put on hold for the
for the immediate future well i've
written a column tonight of the new york
post saying i think he should cancel it
well i think he should rip up the
contract and cancel it because he's
given a statement today harry a very
heartwarming statement about his
grandmother as you would expect they
were close but you can't get away from
the hurt that she must have experienced
in the last two years over all the
shenanigans coming out of california and
in the towards the end of the statement
he says
you know he now wants to honor his
father king charles iii how do you honor
the new king with a book which he says
is going to be searingly
honest and accurate which of course is
what we were told
the oprah interview was what turned out
not to be i think i i think you you
could be right i mean calling for this
to be to be pulled pretty good idea but
i think when you think what the prince
that what the king has said now that he
you know would want you know wants harry
i think really to be part of this new
plan of his you know to take the
monarchy forward i mean he said this
some years ago before we had this does
harry want to be part of it or does
megan in particular
actually want to carry on having their
royal cake and eat it in california and
to not have to abide by the rules of
doing any duty or service or anything
like that but to do exactly what they
want yeah but what makes themselves very
i mean look at the pictures of harry in
the last 24 hours you know he doesn't
look happy in this role i mean certainly
i think he was pleased to be there yeah
you know to to show respect for his
grandmother
and and
his wife megan but
the whole point is that somehow there
has to be a deal struck either we're
going to say goodbye forever and i know
that you've said that the title should
be taken away as well but i think so at
some point if they're going to well paul
let's bring you in here because you're a
supporter of them you know i just think
you the two things aren't compatible you
can't keep royal titles and exploit them
in the way that they're doing for
personal enrichment from the other side
of the world it just doesn't fly i don't
think for most people in this country
interestingly as i'm talking to you
oprah winfrey has said that queen
elizabeth uh seconds death could be an
opportunity for peacemaking speaking at
the toronto film festival she said well
this is what i think i think in all
families you know my father passed
recently this summer when all families
come together for a common ceremony the
ritual of burying your dead there's an
opportunity for peacemaking and
hopefully there will be that she's all
that too uh extra so
obviously there's that opportunity and
obviously it was encouraging to see the
four of them coming out and obviously
everybody would like them to all get on
and to be promoting the new king and the
new monarchy but the problem is i don't
think that this picture is the end of
the problem
and i agree with you actually on this
point piers it's not
the complete picture but what we do have
is we have
a positive progression we have a coming
together because what unfortunately
grieving can do is it can also tear you
apart but we haven't seen that well
harry apparently look you don't know
quite what to believe in the reports but
harry reportedly went up to balmoral
with the rest of the family and left in
the morning and never spoke to william
which is as the queen was dying i find
that an extraordinary effect
but if that is true it shows you the
scale of the rift
but in in terms of moving forward i'd
actually like to think that king charles
had something to do with this as well
apparently he didn't and it's been made
very clear it was all william's idea
his speech i think really reached out to
many of those watching um and i would be
surprised and if therefore on the
sidelines he didn't play a role he's
their father afterwards
you know
you know all these people very well you
know charles extremely well william
extremely well
this has been a hell of a mess and i
feel quite angry that this was all
what the queen had to deal with actually
in the last two years the last thing she
would have wanted particularly when
philip got ill and then died i mean the
last thing she wanted was her
grandchildren at war and everything else
what do you make of it what did you make
of the the reproachment for this picture
of them coming out together
what do you think the answer is going
forward well when the prince said he
loved harry and megan that shook me as
well in his speech and then when they
well i mean when megan got out the car i
was amazed but
obviously william has got to sort of do
something about it and he spoke to his
brother and said look let's
let's make a you know combined effort
here but
they did it because
if they if megan had turned up for the
funeral on monday
all the paper's been talking about megan
and prince of wales and principals the
king doesn't want that he wants it's all
about
the queen yeah nothing else there are no
distractions
whether they'll get back together i
don't know i mean there's there's a big
strong rift between them
bodyguard
she would have hated what's happened
between her two sons wouldn't she well
yeah but she would have done but i i've
said before piers you know what this
this this rift needed was someone to
broker a deal or someone to sort this
out and you know that you know diana had
gone through you said her short life you
know with a great deal of anxiety a
great deal of unhappiness and would have
seen the problems here and would have
seen the the long-term problems here
because the problem is really you know
nobody really wants
quite frankly i know your view and a
view of many thousands of others but
they they need someone to combine this
or to to mend it to find out to find a
solution to put it right and i think
donna would have been the person to deal
with that
is that
it is complicated in the sense that i
mean paula when they left the sussex
when they left the royal family in
britain in january uh 2020 it seems
forever ago down but when they left they
said they were that whatever happened
they were going to uphold the values of
her majesty even though if they weren't
going to be doing duty on her behalf
i don't think even their wildest
supporters could say that their behavior
in the last two years has upheld the
values of her majesty the queen i don't
think that's fair peace really because
what we know she represented duty
honestly
humility
to be very dutiful
um countless charities who can they
continue to they've been enriching
themselves to the tune of hundreds of
millions of people they've been working
very differently to enrich him well they
have to have an
for emergency off their rules
call me cynical and i do yeah but the
work that they do for their charities is
designed to reinforce their royal status
which they then flee to the highest
bidders they've been paid a fortune by
netflix there's this documentary coming
out about their love story which if that
contains more damaging allegations about
the royal family will be another chip to
this new king and the monarchy now you
say damaging allegations about the royal
family what we are actually talking
about is a son talking about his heart
no you're talking about talking about a
daughter-in-law talking about her pain
yeah something that that isn't unusual
in anything i'm not sure how painful it
is to take your prince
from his country back to california and
make yourself super rich trading off
your newly found royal stages i'm not
sure how painful that is particularly to
most millions of people in britain who
are currently on the bread line in this
cost of living crisis her pain i think
needs to be put into some perspective
well the pain she's there is a family
pain
the moment the pain she's called the
royal family and harry's behave is
called the royal family to me outweighs
their own little local difficulties
that you
you don't actually produce any evidence
to prove it i have a problem with that
and when you carry on spewing nonsense
like meghan markle recently just said
this interview last week that she had
you know thank god her children aren't
at school in england because they'd have
50 paparazzi every day we know that's
not going to happen there are rules to
stop that well it wouldn't happen with
the english press but we know that it
would happen with the internet
do you think they're gonna all get
reconciled anytime soon absolutely
should harry get rid of his book
no
really wow ken because i do think that a
lot has been said about the way that
king charles is going to take this
monarchy forward i think what he will do
he will find a way of reconciling harry
with the rest of the royal family quite
well that will be i don't know should he
pump the book
i don't think he should pull the book at
this stage i think what he should do is
actually not do anything with it but
reflect on it and realize seriously what
damage that might do okay arthur last
week
yeah and i think uh
you know the quicker harry gets back
here and starts supporting his father
and his brother yeah the better whether
she comes in or not i don't think see i
don't think that's going to happen
but you know
i think thank you for coming in i know
what this must have meant to you this
last few days so i really appreciate you
coming in okay and uh great that you're
carrying on working with our new king
because he'll need you yeah yeah yeah
82 ken i've got retired yeah paula thank
you both very much evening well coming
next do these scenes of pomp and
ceremony still have a place in modern
britain some think they don't i'll be
debating that with the former head of
the british army lord danny does former
labor mp stephen pound who doesn't and
thinks we should move on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to our extended uh piers
morgan uh tonight most of the nations in
mourning of course from the death of
queen elizabeth ii
[Music]
for some scenes of pomp and pageantry no
longer have a place in modern britain
at the funeral of the lake queen likely
to cost millions of pounds a coronation
for the new king expected next year is
it time to reconsider this kind of
tradition well joining me now is the
former head of the british army lord
danette former labour mp stephen welcome
to both of you steven pound you're not a
fan of all the pomp and pageantry i'm a
huge fan of it so why aren't you i i
think we we're in danger of becoming
morkish about this and overly
sentimental look i think the death of
the greatest monarch in our history the
queen would want dignity and sobriety
and she'd actually want something calm
and sober and serious but she didn't
believe in pomp and panchi tree she
understood the value of that i think
i think to a point i think where i
actually differ uh with maybe public
opinion not for the first time is this
sort of diagnification of business you
know these
acres and acres of flowers and it's
almost as if people um it's like an arms
race of sentimentality people felt like
the queen was a kind of national grammar
the people standing by the side of the
road between balmoral and dundee that
was respectful and it was dignified and
i think the question what's wrong with
leaving flowers outside gates
when people die when anybody dies people
say when you've got people weeping
outside that maybe they're genuinely
upset i shed a tear when the queen died
well
were you not moved by the death of this
immensely movement but on the other hand
i don't want to see her legacy subsumed
into this sort of national grief where
people seem to talk specifically about
the pomp and pageantry because to me you
can't have a monarchy
in a low rent way you either do it
properly with all the bells and whistles
and then you get all the tourism that
comes in which pays for it all either
you do it properly or there's no point
having it well
that's not what they'd say in sweden
it's not what they say in the
netherlands um we were you actually
what's the name of the monarchs of those
two countries
agnetha and um
the other one right you got half of them
right but my point being nobody knows
who they are yeah yeah but they probably
do in the netherlands but yeah
right well let me bring in lord you've
been sitting quietly listening to this i
have too much morkishness uh too much
pom-pom pageantry we shouldn't be going
down this road what do you think well i
actually i think we're doing it just
right at the present moment um my wife
and i were at sandringham this morning
where there are a lot of flowers but it
was a very respectful there wasn't a lot
of weeping and gnashing of teeth and
whatever it was very respectful people
were being very quiet they were talking
to each other they've told people they'd
never met before and everybody was just
making the obvious comments that he was
a wonderful queen and the other thing
that people are saying is particularly
with the proclamation on saturday and
apocalypses around the country yesterday
just how well his majesty king charles
is fitting into the room and i think
that's really reassuring also a lot of
the pomp and pageantry is military
driven right it's it's it's the armed
forces at their best this shows off i
think a large part of what the monarch
is the commander-in-chief of the armed
forces
that's why i like it as well it's about
the defense of the realm it's about the
country it matters to me well it's part
of the fabric of our nation i mean we do
these things we actually do them very
well we do them i think it's fair to say
probably better than than anybody else
and your earlier point just to play it
back to you because we do it so well it
does attract north little people to come
and he actually is very good for
terrorism it is that isn't a driver in
its end in
its own right it's a very good spin-off
and very useful stephen pan i mean the
point is we can go the american way we
could become a republic and you could
have presidents
uh who last four or eight years
none of them have come anywhere near the
popularity of this queen no i i couldn't
agree more i mean this is the the
interesting thing is i mean my i don't
abolish the monarchy no i i think in the
long term the monarchy will will wither
away as we know it in the present time
we're seeing no sign of this with the
scene
i think the idea of a constitutional
monarchy where every member of
parliament has to swear an oath of
allegiance to her majesty or his majesty
their heirs and successes everything we
do is done in the king of the queen's
name i cannot see that surviving for
much longer but like albert you know the
prime minister of australia and like
jacinda arden i think this is not the
time to be talking about it this is not
the time to consider the future of the
monarchy this is the time to well
actually i think it is the time to
consider the future the monarchy because
we now have a new monarch
and
what's a better time i mean it's it
seems to me the perfect time
let's let the dust settle and let's see
how i mean at the moment we we have a
monarch in king charles who has actually
in some ways broken the mode of being
the header of being the prince of world
he's got involved we all know about the
you know the spider letters and the bits
and pieces and we always had an edema i
mean we paid for someone to squeeze his
toothpaste and he stayed out of politics
he's crossed that line whether he will
now continue what was he wrong about
yeah i think to actually involve himself
in town planning what was he what's he
been wrong about out of interest well i
mean i have to say his development in in
cornwall uh you know
the the idea of this particular his idea
of creating these sort of little
poundvilles over there they call them in
cornwall i i think he got it wrong
because he had this sort of quinlan
terry idea but on the big picture of
things like climate change and stuff
he's been proven right isn't it i think
he was right to you know as rights raise
the alarm a lot earlier than many
politicians prince philip did it even
sooner than him and prince philip was
there absolutely right i think they're
right to do this
he may be challenged to do it as a
monarch as prince of wales i thought he
was right i think that's the point i
think actually he's already signaled
that actually king charles is going to
behave differently he has friends of
wales and i think that's really really
important and to be honest he spent the
last 50 years 70 years waiting to be
king and i think it's been very
interesting and that he has got himself
involved um you know the spidery
handwriting letters to ministers asking
questions um
i've read a few of those that is i
thought he was completely entitled to do
that and actually it showed he was
diligent and he cared and he what he was
really doing was challenging ministers
yeah to make right policy decisions but
he's already signaled that actually that
way of behavior he cannot continue with
one another
yeah and i think the only chance he will
get will be on the weekly audience for
the prime minister exactly and it'll be
interesting to be a fly on the wall it
will because we're never going to know
what we aren't and that's the one
leak-proof conversation that goes on in
the united kingdom on a weekly basis and
i reckon there'll be very interesting
conversations
he won't hold back no but we're never
going to find out if he wielded
influence or not i think in a way you do
because of soft power of being the
mother let me ask you what i've got you
this is obviously the biggest story in
this country but what's happening in
ukraine in the last 48 hours is no less
important uh there seems to have been a
massive shift
in the the what's going on there where
the russians seem to be dominant but now
they seem to be in retreat in large
parts of the donbass region what do you
make of this and is it possible that the
ukrainians could actually win this war
now well there's two questions let's
just take the first one first it's
fascinating what is happening
what the ukrainians have managed to do
is pull off what i would call
an operational level degree of surprise
they've talked for the last four five or
six weeks about a counter-offensive in
the south in the curson sort of north of
crimea area
such that the russians brought some of
their better troops from the donbass to
reinforce around kirsan that having
happened the ukrainians with their
heavy equipment provided by the west to
better trained soldiers have attacked
vigorously around kharkiv in the north
and they've broken through and they've
broken so far through that they've
caused mayhem in the in the in the
russian river so what will now happen
well
um is the worry that when he's as people
have always thought if putin gets
cornered he's so invested in this war
now that if he gets cornered he might do
something like
launch a tactical nuclear strike
we may have thought he was crazy to
attack in the first place in february
actually i don't think that's right i
think he does retain a sufficient degree
of rationality to know that the balance
of mutual destruction which was what
held the peace as it were during the
cold war is still there even if he
thinks if he loses the war he may not
survive he's got other options the other
option that he's got is to stop calling
as a special military operation to
actually declare war that changes the
law in russia he can then bring in
conscription he can actually mobilize
the rest of russia's military and he
said he either goes all in or he has to
basically fail uh he's got to go all in
or he probably will fail
i mean
a month ago
i couldn't see how we could be in the
situation that we are now um the world
might say the russians are going to
leave ukraine they would never go
voluntarily i thought the ukrainians
could never kick them out and the west
would never put a sort of kuwait style
operation together to throw them out but
what we're seeing now that america is
engaged with other nato nations and
particularly the americans they're
barreling so much equipment they are
really good high-tech credit to
president biden absolutely and when
uncle sam gets himself engaged he makes
a difference and that's what we're
seeing actually with ukraine's i'm
british support as well
it is making a difference my worry just
the present moment is the ukrainians in
their enthusiasm will overreach
themselves and take and take a bloody
nose
so i think this operation will develop a
certain distance and then it will stop
there'll be a certain amount more
maneuver before winter comes it'll
probably go into the deep freeze over
winter and then we'll see where we are
you know what i was in ukraine a few
weeks ago and i don't think i've ever
met a more determined people and the one
common refrain from all of them whether
it was the mayor of kiev vitale
klitschko the former overweight champion
whether it was president zielenski or
whether it's just random people i met in
the street we're not giving the russians
an inch of our territory and we will die
to make sure we don't and that was to a
man and woman of the people i met they
are extraordinary people and we saw um
because they've had this reverse on the
battlefield um huge attack on the power
station putting that kharkiv area into
darkness that will just actually
reinforce the determination of the
ukrainians you can't you couldn't bomb
london in 1940 under submission we
couldn't actually remind me a lot of the
of the spirit we had here
great to see you thank you very much do
you think there's a vietnam analogy
there no i don't actually i actually
think the ukrainians are going to
prevail eventually in this well
i think he's he's made a massive mistake
yeah but you can have a massively
technologically advanced nation like the
united states or russia thinking that
they can actually invade or you know
occupy and defeat a force and they can't
the americans didn't win
in that sense yeah i mean there isn't
barry i don't even go on as long as my
point yeah oh that was a long drawn out
thing i don't think it will be that way
i think oh no no it didn't i think the
american support in particular is so big
now they're getting the equipment that
zelensky can't want and even even the
germans are coming of course the long
game is what putin is hoping for of
course that actually the enthusiasm
whether you're right now looks to me
like it might not be the long game he
wants thank you both very much indeed
good to see you both well the pomp and
pageantry that mr powell wants to get
rid of was on display today during king
charles's speech to parliament
westminster hall and it was magnificent
let's take a
look i cannot help but feel the weight
of history
which surrounds us
and which reminds us
of the vital parliamentary traditions
to which members of both houses
dedicate yourselves
with such personal commitment
for the betterment of us all she set an
example
of selfless duty
which
with god's help
and your councils
i am resolved faithfully to follow
[Music]
well we're witnessing the very best of
british right now one of the most
difficult times this country has had to
go through which is the death of our
great and beloved monarch the greatest
monarch of all time
sadness ceremony and some solemn
celebrations too these of course are all
part of the customs and traditions
underpin the continuity of the monarchy
as an institution they're intended to
show through custom and class that life
goes on that the united kingdom and this
monarchy goes on i think most of us feel
very proud about that
most people were moved by the late
queen's death and also believe that most
people are behind our new king charles
but there's an important point here that
shouldn't be compulsory we don't live in
north korea and we've seen protesters
arrested for booing at proclamations for
the new king for holding up placards
saying they don't want a new king or a
monarchy another protester dragged away
by police and arrested today for
heckling prince andrew now you might
share my view that it's completely
inappropriate for them to be doing this
when the queen's hearse is there you
might find it wrong and objectionable
that they want to get rid of the
monarchy or don't agree with the
principle
but and it's an important but in this
country you have the right to disagree
to have your opinion
and to protest loudly if you see fit and
there are legitimate discussions to be
had now about the future of the monarchy
under king charles iii and the future of
the commonwealth there will be debates
vigorous debates about how a monarchy
fits in at all with a vigorous thriving
new democracy which champions free
speech but a constitutional monarchy has
to make the case itself time and time
again they rule by the consent of the
people that's how this works that's part
of why king charles will visit every
country in the uk this week to make that
case
silencing dissent like this
is a bit disturbing it feels over the
top
it's not british
well joining me now is former vogue
editor alexander shulman talk tv
contributor esther krakow documentary
maker john
bright who has worked with king charles
for 15 years his documentary born to be
king is on iplayer now welcome to all of
you uh and from westminster we have fox
news correspondent alex hogan who i'll
come to in a moment alexandra great to
see you all first of all um
the right to protest
i'm a staunch monarchist i believe in
the royal family i support the king and
i feel very upset about what's happened
in the last few days but when i see
people protesting about the monarchy i
think that is part of a democracy what
do you think well i think we live in a
time when there are so many questions
about free speech don't we you know i
mean i hate the way that we can't
everybody feels worried about what they
say whether they write something whether
they publish something when they say
something and if you feel that way you
have to also say well it's okay for
people to make vile comments as the
queen's coffin is in front of them so um
i agree with you yeah i mean that's look
it's nobody likes to say i don't like to
see it i say nobody some people don't
care i don't like to see it and it is
disrespectful but to see people being
arrested
for protesting about the monarchy
uh i don't like that i think it's it's
completely shambolic and i think it's
very anti-british um but i have been
vocal and i said you know people that
have haven't even waited for it to be 24
hours before effectively uh trolling the
queen's death it's tacky and it's
disrespectful but i absolutely will
fight for their right to say that and i
think with the more harm is being done
by silencing people regardless of what
their opinions are than actually letting
them speak and you know demonstrating
our democracy at its finest
john you've made a lot of films with uh
then prince of wales now the king first
of all how did you feel when you heard
this
seismic news that harmonic was changing
and this man that you know so well was
now our king
well i suppose
i was aware of the plans that have been
laid over a long time and i was very
interested to see how it was all going
to pan out but obviously there's already
been a change in him i mean he's the
same man
but
he's got you you really feel that he's
he's sort of he's grappled with his
destiny and he's he's accepted it and
he's doing it now with something he's
been waiting to do not because he wants
to to get on with it but but because
he's expecting it would come you know
him better than many people what's he
like
he's a very gracious man i would say to
start with
um i think he's also a very emotional
man and that's not something one
associates with the royal family
normally
i think we we've seen that since he
since he became king and his broadcast
last friday was really quite emotional
and i think i think that's going to be a
hallmark of his reign that it's i don't
mean sort of bursting into tears all the
time but it's it's there's a very deep
feeling there
and i i've actually
been with him to the opera
and
we went to see la boheme at covent
garden and in the last act tears were
running down his face really yes
it's quite extraordinary it doesn't
surprise me he strikes me as an
emotional man
alex hogan fox news correspondent who's
over at bucky palace alex tell me about
america's reaction to this i've been
doing a lot of uh interviews for various
fox shows i'm actually going to be
co-anchoring the funeral for fox which
i'm very honored to be doing um it seems
to me that america is feeling the loss
of this queen many americans almost as
much as we are
that's true there's this immense feeling
of loss not only here in the uk in the
us and really around the world again
this was an influential figure that was
known
pretty much everywhere across the globe
and there is this deep sense of tragedy
not only watching a woman people grew up
in and new but also seeing the loss for
the family members today in that really
emotional video where we saw the
children of the queen standing around
her casket in st giles and how
emotionally tolling that was for them
and to be able to witness that and see
some of the emotion just like we were
talking about it is a moment that people
around the world are watching just
because of the magnitude and the
notoriety of this woman all of the
things she was able to do in 70 years on
the throne in 96 years of life it is a
moment that people for the next week
continually will watch because it does
matter to them it hits home with them
they've spent years watching this woman
and to see her live a life so
prominently and to be even meeting with
the prime minister in her last days it's
just remarkable to see and i think
that's why this story touches people
really across the globe yeah and you
know as i'm talking to you just been
revealed that president biden will have
dispensation to take his armored beast
car to westminster abbey for the funeral
unlike most other world leaders who are
going to have to share a bus
it it's going to be interesting to see
how people arrive everyone was told of
these diplomats these foreign
dignitaries not to travel by private
jets or private helicopter and to take
these shared buses of course there is a
massive security concern that these
foreign dignitaries will need to grapple
with just looking at the city of london
alone with the influx of people that
have come in from around the country and
around the world to pay tribute to the
queen it's going to be an immense
security concern for these
diplomats who will be arriving here not
only for their own safety but also for
the safety of the people who are here in
london but we do not expect president
biden to be traveling on that bus and of
course we do see air force one uh on
these types of trips it'll be
interesting to see how many other
foreign dignitaries
do abide by this request to take the
shared bus it certainly will i think a
lot of egos will be at play um listen
thank you very much alex i really
appreciate you joining me
thank you
alexandra you know king charles and his
queen console camilla quite well through
your previous incarnation as former
editor of vogue
what are they like when you've dealt
with them
you describe them to me well the queen
consort um i have huge admiration for um
i know you know her very well and she's
got just this fantastic dry sense of
humor
and this ability to make you feel like
she really engages with you
and she's no fuss and i think it's
really interesting that dynamic because
you know they've been together on and
off for years and
king charles is a very different type of
man you know he's been brought up always
in the sort of epicenter of privilege
and this very rarefied
life and i think what's wonderful is the
way that she's been able to make him
feel relaxed
and supported in a way that i honestly
think that were she not around he would
be finding this
much more i cannot agree i mean i think
i described
camilla earlier as as you know she is to
prince well king charles as he knows it
takes so much time right i mean we keep
slipping up but um to king charles what
prince philip was to the queen you know
she is the rock in his life and always
really has been and they've endured a
lot
in all their time together but what's
interesting is she's never given really
a proper interview about anything to do
with her own life she's done particular
things for book clubs or whatever but
never about what she's been through
she's never complained she's never
explained and in that sense she's
followed the path
of the queen and the queen mother who've
always believed you don't need to do all
that kind of thing that you just need to
just do your duty and the public
eventually if you do it well and you
show that you love your country and the
people they'll come around to you yeah i
think it's quite a kind of british thing
that though isn't it you know so the
world in a way that camilla comes from
is quite a never complain never explain
world and you don't you know you don't
hang out your dirty washing in public
and you don't moan about people and you
might do it around the dinner table but
you don't bang on to everyone else about
it and i think so that's so genuine
yesterday i have known him a long time
but i'm 57 you're a lot younger than me
as a young person what do you want to
see from this new king he's in his 70s
but you know by comparison to his mother
he's a younger monarch what do you want
to see him do i think i want to just see
him be unapologetically proud to be
british which sounds weird right because
you wouldn't hear this from from a young
person but i do think that my my
generation really needs to see that kind
of exam example because we don't really
have that we we're kind of growing up
you know most republicans in this
country are actually young most people
that don't see the value in the monarchy
are actually young most people that you
know whinge about the commonwealth that
are actually understanding the
commonwealth the people in the
commonwealth are actually very young so
i think just being an example and
holding the fort is all really i can
expect from him because this is a it's a
you know a very old institution it's
obviously given us so much but i think
young people really need to see the
value of that for it to continue and i
think that's what we can do john uh is
that enough
or is he going to be determined to make
his mark by not just being the
continuity monarch
oh i don't
he's going to be both the same and
different i'm sure that two things are
going to happen at the same time i'm a
classic monarch position
but i think the thing is i'm not sure
that i agree with you esther because i
think
he has a great
that there's a great pull for a lot of
young people with him i think if it was
another 73 year old
it would be
it might be a problem but but really
because of the prince's trust i think
there are a lot of young people who
really identify with him and it's been
striking to see the crowds
how many young people are out there you
know wanting the best thing he's doing i
can tell you and i've said this to his
people the more he's out engaging with
the people of all ages and particularly
young people the more you can feel the
warmth from those people they're buying
back in
maybe against what they thought they
would do back into this whole const
construct of a monarchy and two two
women kissing him yeah i mean you know
one on the show
then kissed me
she had two kings in the same day boom
boom um it's very interesting though i
think that kind of interaction is key
and he's very good at it yeah because i
filmed him in durham um about three
years ago and he was up there it was a
beautiful day and there were a whole lot
of students university students who were
there lining the you know along the
barriers and he stopped and the thing is
when he shakes hands with people he
listens to what they've got to say and
he finds a connection he was saying how
many essays do you write a week and they
said oh i know one he said well i had
three when i was at cambridge you have
it so easy and you know and then he met
someone well the last time i saw him was
itv about four years ago he came and
came around the rtv buildings with with
his queen console as she is now and he
looked at me he met suzanna reed and
then he turned to me and he went
good god are you still around which i
thought was very funny and then we had a
very funny chat about donald trump who i
just interviewed uh he just become uh
the first interview he gives is becoming
president of british media and he was i
said that by the way the
president sends his regards
intrigued by it and then later i sat
next to uh camilla at a dinner just
after they'd been with trump and that
was a very interesting conversation i
won't reveal it but it's very
interesting but what i got the sense was
that they are
they're able to deal like the queen
they're able to deal with all types of
people they know that part of the job is
you have to meet a lot of controversial
people and the job of a monarch is
actually not to show which ones you like
and don't like and then i think charles
is as good that as his mother was
he's had a lot of time to practice a lot
of signs of practice the greatest
apprentice in history thank you all very
much uh to my pack here we're coming up
next king charles hasn't been shy when
voicing political matters reportedly
brian of the government's positive send
migrants to rwanda for example as
appalling but will he have to now reign
in as monarch he says he will
but will he labor's jonathan ashworth
joins me next
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well back in june clarence house was
forced to release a statement
reiterating that king charles would be
politically neutral once he inherited
the throne it came after the then prince
branded the government's controversial
policy to send migrants to rwanda as
appalling well joining me now is shadow
secretary of state for working pensions
and privy council member jonathan
ashford thank you you're my first labour
minister shadow minister come on thank
you very much well i'm really pleased to
be here and i always enjoy coming on
your shows piers and it's great that
you're back on our tv thank you very
much thank you we'll use it as a promo i
probably get you fired um but good to
see you you were there for this
accession ceremony on saturday yeah as a
privy councilman what was that like oh i
mean it was extraordinary and
the reason i was there because i'm a
privy counselor that means as an mp i'm
allowed to be called i am called the
right honourable um
and it was 200 of us in this room
um
it was an extraordinary moment it was a
real history it was real history in the
in in the making of course all of us in
there
had not been at an accession council
before uh so we're all slightly nervous
none of us want to get it wrong we don't
want to bow at the right moment and say
the right thing of course and of course
and in fairness i'm of a different
political party to the government but i
thought penny mordant who
oversaw proceedings in with a as the
lord president i thought she was superb
and then we were ushered into the throne
room where we heard king charles uh give
his address to hers uh and it was quite
a moving moment yes i mean i thought his
speech this morning to all the
mps and peers was really
spot on again yeah in fact every move
he's made so far despite what must be
overwhelming grief he's feeling for the
loss of his mother coming so soon after
his father died i just think it's
incredibly impressive what he's been
doing so far yeah i think today
strangely enough was the moment it
really did hit me the
weight of history on his shoulders as we
were sat in that westminster hall which
is the oldest part of the he looked
quite emotional when you're all saying
god saved the king
i was watching him luckily for me i just
happened to get a seat which was closer
to the front and i could see i had a
very good view of him i thought he
looked very emotional
i thought we could he could i could see
him if you like i thought him processing
the magnitude of the moment and of
course
as well as this great these great
constitutional duties that are placed
upon him and he is carrying them out
superbly with aplomb
he's also grieving as well because he is
he's lost his mother who he's very close
to look we're living in a dramatic cost
of living crisis which has been slightly
overshadowed caused by what's happening
but it's real and it's ongoing for
people there will be a number of labour
party members and labour party voters
who will be instinctively thinking all
this pomp and pageantry is fine but what
about my ability to pay
for my kids school meals
what do you say
as a labor shadow minister about this do
you think we had a debate just now about
whether we should still be doing all
this pomp and pageantry what do you feel
about that but i think what's important
is that we remember that the
constitutional settlement we have a
constitutional monarch actually
underpins and secures our democracy
and
it's only be a few days more if you like
when parliament will resume and the
great issues that are affecting of state
the great issues which are impacting on
people across the country will be
debated again robustly and
democratically in parliament and that
democracy is safeguarded by our
constitution you're a sports fan did you
agree with football being cancelled i
understood why it was cancelled was it
with the hindsight a mistake well i
understood the way cricket went about it
seemed to be far better to me well i
think football is going to be back on
this next weekend i think i think some
games not all yeah yeah no i i
understood why it was council
did you you didn't think that pac
stadium singing the national anthem
would have been a good mark of respect
well minute silence
well i think we'll certainly see that
when the games resume hopefully this
weekend but look different people
different organizations will want to pay
their tributes in their own ways i
certainly know the leicester mp where
our city has come together and we are as
you know an incredibly diverse city um
yeah but i mean the way you're playing
it must be a relief not to be having any
games at all
i don't know
but let's see how long brenda rushes
yeah exactly that's but um you know it's
just about the point in the city like
leicester tremendously diverse
mosques temples jain temples sikh
guidewires synagogues churches of all
come together all been expressing their
thanks to her her late majesty
should the king now king charles iii he
was notorious as prince of wales for
firing off his spidery letters to
ministers about all sorts of issues he
said he won't do that kind of thing
anymore is it really important do you
think that the monarch whoever it is but
particularly one who's been so vocal
politically before in terms of writing
to government ministers directly is it
right that he should now be completely
impartial and stop that kind of thing
well he will obviously have no role in
party politics quite rightly but i think
when he was the prince of wales he he
argued or perhaps people on his behalf
argued that he's going around the
country he's listening to people all the
time he does a lot of charity work and
it's only right that he passes on to
ministers what he picks up on what he
hears so ministers can reflect on that
and improve the the decisions that they
are making and i am sure as king as
monarch he will not interfere
politically quite rightly
but i am sure as he goes around the
country and meets people he will want to
pass on what he's hearing final question
a lot of protests not a lot a few people
protesting some have been manhandled
uh some have been arrested do you agree
with that or do you think people should
be entitled if they want to say they
don't believe in a monarchy i mean
people should be able to say that of
course i should we're a democracy and
these protests are very smart i've not
because i've been doing so much today in
my parliamentary uses i've not seen the
clips and so on on twitter
look i mean people should be able to
protest they should be able to have
their say
um you know i think it's pretty clear
from the the huge outpouring of grief
and love and admiration
that the majority the vast majority want
to maintain the monarchy but obviously
one or two people are always going to
protest that's that's life that's
democracy it is uh that's why i used to
come on good morning britain and let me
shout at you and i look forward to doing
that again when this is all over
jonathan ashworth so come back again
soon very good to see you thank you very
much for coming in well coming up next
some protesters are arrested for
interrupting the proclamations of the
king charles is it distasteful
inappropriate arrestable or free speech
one of those protesters who shouted who
elected him and was arrested joins me
next
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk tv
[Music]
a growing number of anti-monarchy
protesters have been arrested in the
proclamation of king charles iii today
one protest was thrown to the ground and
arrested after heckling prince andrew
is arresting him for a breach of the
peace a step too far completely
inappropriate with me now is simon hill
who was arrested yesterday after he
called out who elected him when he
passed a ceremony in oxford mark in the
new monarch's accession legal journalist
ava santina tv i talked to your
contributor esther krakow join me again
simon hill on the face of it this seems
absurd um
you walked past a proclamation being
read out and shouted who elected him
that's it that was your offense i i
shouted out who elected him i wasn't
even near the front of the proclamation
i wasn't planning to protest i didn't
have a placard i was on my way home from
church
and um as uh what made you shout out
well the the proclamation began with um
uh expression of grief for the previous
monarch and of course i would never
interrupt an expression of grief but
when they announced charles to be our
only rightful lord and king well that
isn't something i i felt i should accept
in the 21st century i appreciate other
people have different views so i called
out who elected him a couple of people
near me told me to shut up fair enough
that's their free speech i responded by
expressing why i thought um
we shouldn't have a head of state
without being consulted and then
suddenly there were these three security
guards grabbing me pushing me backwards
then the police took hold of me uh led
me away uh arrested me handcuffed me
apparently for expressing an opinion and
you know other people have different
opinions i strongly support their right
to free speech there's something very
worrying if you can't express a a
different i mean i don't agree with your
opinion at all but i certainly don't
understand why you've been arrested well
no the democratic society for shouting
out who elected him um what's happened
since well when they when they arrested
me uh to begin with there's a lot of
confusion as to the grounds for the
arrest they kept contradicting each
other about why i've been arrested when
i tried to ask them eventually they
de-arrested me they asked me to do an
interview i said what does that mean
they took away the arrest or well i it
was unclear to me because at first they
said i'd be arrested if i gave an
interview i said i wanted a lawyer
present if i was to be interviewed
um and then they said i'd be arrested
and asked back for an interview and i
could still be charged and then they
released me um
and at that point they told me i'd been
arrested under a particular act the
police act passed earlier this year but
later on the police press office was
telling journalists i've been arrested
under a different act so all a bit of a
match don't even seem to know on what
grounds they're arrested right ava
i just doesn't make me feel comfortable
in this country that people were being
arrested for shouting who elected him
you're perfectly entitled not to want to
believe in a monarchy no trouble totally
i mean this is under the despotic bill
that was introduced under pretty patel
our now former home secretary earlier in
the year a few generous we were told the
police told us it was under section five
of the public order event
so public order act 1986 it applies to
behavior deemed likely to cause
harassment alarm or distress i'm not
quite sure how who elected him could
cause harassment alarm or distress
who elected i'm sure saying who elected
him constitutes harassment alarm or
distress yeah no i think it would make
more sense if he had been charged which
was similar in edinburgh there was sort
of some talk that they were getting
arrested under this bill under pretty
patel's bill because that's very
subjective that line in that so any
any protest that can be described as
disturbing the peace you could be done
for but this is totally bizarre the idea
that you could be express an opinion
anti-monarchy
i think we can all agree this seems like
a massive overreach by the police a bit
more complicated is what happened in
edinburgh today as the queen's
purse went past
one protester jumped out because prince
andrew was walking behind this it's his
mother absolutely understand why he
wanted to be there to pay his respect
but i can't understand why some members
of the public would feel aggrieved about
a public display
or appearance by somebody who's recently
been so disgraced and so one young
member of the crowd began bellowing
things about prince andrew and he was
manhandled and dragged out of there
and i i'm not sure what i feel about
that because it did seem completely
insensitive to do it in front of the
queen's heart having said that i
understand why emotions right might run
high about andrew being center stage of
some of this i'm more inclined to to
believe and i'm trying to be as gracious
as i can to the people that arrested him
that it was because there was some sort
of
fear for his security
as opposed to anything else because
that's the only reason that i can
possibly think the crowd weren't really
responding to it yeah but you who would
right i mean behind a barrier exactly
you couldn't have gotten over there
exactly but you know i don't think
anyone thinks prince andrews i mean what
do you think of simon of that incident
yeah i mean personally i wouldn't
protest at a funeral uh procession i'd
never protest an act of mourning but
that's on taste grounds more than yeah
but um but the fact that something is
tasteful or something i don't like isn't
a reason for it to be illegal it's not
we can't arrest everyone doing anything
distasteful and you know to put it
bluntly a lot of people will ask why is
it not andrew who's being arrested or
investigated rather than rather
perfectly reasonable point and many will
think if you pay someone off in a civil
call action to tune in millions of
dollars to avoid a court appearance some
people will ask that question and if
you're in that position of privilege
um you know some would ask if andrew was
in a different social position would he
be more like didn't have the money to do
that correct exactly
simon hill i don't know why you're
arrested it seems wrong i don't agree
with you uh but for what it's worth he
shouldn't have been arrested in my
opinion uh we live in a country where i
thought free speech was the cornerstone
of our democracy but from what happened
to you i'm beginning to doubt that very
much but thank you very much for coming
in well thank you and there's been
several similar arrests in in london and
edinburgh yeah i don't i just think
we'll take it case by case but certainly
in your case it seemed a ridiculous
overreach but thank you for coming in
thank you you two stay with me we're
gonna have one last segment about the
future the commonwealth no pressure
these are big issues
well commonwealth nations uh are all
deliberating now of course with the new
monarch what they should be doing do
they want to become republics antigua is
the latest in the caribbean for example
to say that they'll have a referendum
within the next three years we'll
discuss
all this next
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
well besides the uk king charles iii is
now head of state in 14 commonwealth
countries as well as remaining head of
the commonwealth of 56 nations but with
the late queen's passing will we now see
at the beginning of more countries
following barbados in becoming republics
joining me now as former bbc royal
correspondent wesley kerr talk to your
contributor esther cracker and political
journalist avery stay with me wesley
great to see you um what is the
difference between a commonwealth
country and commonwealth realms
a commonwealth country is one of 56 in
this free association of countries there
were seven members of the commonwealth
when elizabeth became queen
um so it you could argue it's a great
success it's in pr terms it's flipped
the bad of empire into something
positive
and then some countries when they became
independent choose to keep keep the
british monarch and that that goes back
to canada in the mid 19th century which
became the first dominion as they were
then called then australia new zealand
south africa so it was largely a white
club before the second world war
including the irish free straight
newfound newfoundland then when india
became independent and was broken up
into india and pakistan
and sri lanka
so it then wanted to become a republic
so they had this new formula let's make
the monarch head of the commonwealth
and then let's allow republics to stay
in the commonwealth so 90 percent of the
members of the commonwealth of the
population of the commonwealth are in um
asia and africa and live in republics
but there's these countries australia
canada new zealand jamaica being the
largest in population terms i can't see
the first three immediately becoming
republics australia looked at that we're
seeing like antigua now referendum
within three years and so on
could there be a bit of a domino effect
here well i think it's be i remember
being on tour with the queen in the
caribbean 30 years ago and being told
this will be the last visit to jamaica
and jamaica still hasn't had it needs a
referendum in jamaica i think that's the
key thing have the ones who've gone the
public regretted it
um i don't think it makes all that much
difference because they all chose to
keep the british monarch um maybe it's
good for tourism i don't think but
barbados i don't think feels any less
english than i did before what do you
think i mean obviously we've seen in
recent royal trips this question of
whether britain and the monarchy in
particular should be apologizing looking
back over the the worst side of the
british empire and so on what do you
feel about that would that does that
actually make any difference as a
descendant of slaves i've always been
aware of the history of britain but i
don't blame my contemporary brits for
the terrible wrongs of the past i think
that
better aid better terms of trade is much
better than reparations
um
i think apologies charles charles has
made an apology william made an apology
i i don't think that actually makes the
difference no i agree i think you're
right i think treating it as a
partnership of equals that will be the
future of the commonwealth is it not
from this end of the telescope not about
the monarchy but about actually things
that are common purpose it's very
important i think that the commonwealth
remains strong for king charles iii and
he'll feel very strongly about that
you're from ghana originally the
commonwealth country what do you feel
about this i think most people that are
against the commonwealth don't really
understand the commonwealth or the
people that live within the commonwealth
and i think actually many people within
the commonwealth are more an extension
of traditional british values than
people within this country that are you
know staunch republicans or don't don't
appreciate the monarchy or the um the
the
well the monarchy or the commonwealth
you know it says something it's it's a
testament to the commonwealth the fact
that they're countries that weren't even
part of the british empire that have
chosen to join the commonwealth and it
says something about sort of the
continuation of british values and what
it means for the world you know and what
it means for our globalized world now i
think you know the fact that they're
choosing sort of a greater alliance with
something like the uk and the
commonwealth as opposed to aligning
themselves more with china for instance
that says a lot about what it's what
british values mean around the world
what do you think do i see the value in
the commonwealth yeah i don't think that
we treat people from the commonwealth
very well in this country so i i can't
personally see the value but i'm not
going to sit here and tell you how to
feel about it i mean
i've been badly treated as somebody um
conceived in jamaica all my life here i
don't feel like i'm like i think of bad
things that have happened to me yeah and
you know police narcissists but i don't
think i've been back are you alluding to
the windrush scandal
definitely i think you know growing up
loving benjamin zephaniah as an author
and you know his understanding of coming
here and just feeling totally alienated
and being told that this was the mother
country and he was going to be welcomed
here and they're being treated
he doesn't feel that now though
i could tell you terrible stories of
when i was young and i think and this is
so much better than many countries i
think it's a generational thing as well
because i had my my um my fam i have
older family members that came to the uk
before i was as teenagers and their
experience to mine is completely
different and like i said you know
nothing is perfect but it's a testament
to to britain and to british values the
fact that even with all of this there's
still countries that choose to join the
commonwealth as opposed to aligning yeah
i think it's a really good point but
you've got to look at the situation with
like nurses at the moment where are we
looking for nurses and we are going to
mainly
sorry i've got to leave it there it's a
good debate though we should have more
on this i think it's a really
interesting conversation which charles
will now have to have as our king thank
you all very much thank you for coming
in appreciate it that's all for us
tonight uh
we'll have more tomorrow and more every
night this week about the loss of this
great monarch and also the future under
king charles the third good night
[Music]
this is talk tv news
good evening i'm zora suleiman king
charles iii and his siblings have held a
vigil in honour of their mother queen
elizabeth the king stood in silence
alongside princess anne and princess
andrew and edward next to the late
queen's coffin which is now lying at
rest in edinburgh thousands of mourners
have been queueing to see the coffin
earlier the king led the royal family in
a procession from holyrood palace before
a service of reflection at st giles
cathedral he also addressed parliament
where he paid tribute to his darling
mother
and the premier league will return this
weekend but three games will be
postponed due to events surrounding
queen elizabeth's funeral chelsea
liverpool man united leeds and brighton
versus crystal palace won't go ahead
well that's the latest stay tuned for
more coverage of queen elizabeth's death
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you